ok mais sans électronique ça va être la
seconde près il va falloir calculer très
vite quand on sera là où en plus on n'a
plus d'ingénieurs d'avoir eu
non non vous déconnez j'ai pas
l'habilitation pour faire ça je suis la
nouvelle directrice de la nasa alors je
vous la donne
félicitations win
j'ai une colopathie
le syndrome du côlon irritable
et j'ai le mal des transports tu as dit
que tu as toujours voulu être astronaute
je souffre d'anxiété débilitante que si
si la lune est vraiment tel que tu
penses il nous faut un mec et structures
east
en combinaison
[Musique]
20 juillet
à l'école on nous a appris que apollo 11
a perdu le contact avec la terre pendant
deux minutes
c'est faux
ils ont trouvé quelque chose ce jour là
qu'ils ont caché pendant 50 ans
et maintenant
il est trop tard pour l'arrêter
plage spéciale le gouverneur vient
d'ordonner l'évacuation de toute la côte
ouest
et la seule chance de survie
[Musique]
c'est toute l'amérique
a suivi cinq extinctions
celestis meilleur goût sera la sixième
on est mort
non on est juste à l'intérieur de la une
c'est la phrase la plus culte jamais
prononcé
[Musique]